we got to remind you May 10th the first
ever it's an event first ever live taste
buds live streaming we've been selling
tickets to that you can get an exclusive
link and watch the premiere of this live
streaming also going to be here in New
York City in front of a live audience
surprises all sorts of different things
happening all sorts of crazy battles
gonna happen surprises from every angle
stay tuned for all the information and
we got live dates of our own yes
what's up guys come see me on the road
right now go to savocanocomedy.com for
tickets uh April 7th I'm in Seattle with
the guys at the climate pledge Arena
April 8th at the Keller Auditorium in
Portland we have two shows the second
one still has tickets uh Bangor Maine on
April 27th the Wang theater in Boston
three shows April 28th and 29th that
weekend uh two shows are sold out so
there's one show left to get tickets
then we go Maverick Center in Utah May
5th Bellco Theater in Denver May 6th uh
let's see what else here then we go into
Texas we're going to uh Arlington Austin
at the Moody Center and Sugarland Texas
at the Smart Financial Center May 19 20
and 21 and just to round out this summer
right now these are the last dates I
have before the new dates are announced
it's gonna be a lot of new dates
announced soon so if you don't hear it
just check back but we got Columbus on
June 2nd Cleveland on June 3rd at the
rocket mortgage field house and the
Schottenstein Center respectively two
huge venues there the Fox Theater in
Detroit on June 4th June 15th we're in
Minneapolis uh June 16th Des Moines at
Wells Fargo Arena June 17th the T-Mobile
Center in Kansas City and the last dates
right now before we announce new who won
the ones Nashville Grand Ole Opry July
27th uh Cambridge Field House in
Indianapolis on the 28th and St Louis we
got two in St Louis on the 29th at the
stifle theater and one there's tickets
available so hope to see you on the road
Impractical Jokers every Thursday nights
at 10 brand new episodes right now on
TBS and true and please go to our store
check out our merch we're about to sell
out of this and we're about to launch
new ones so this is the last chance to
get some merch I'll see you guys on the
road
Joe DeRosa here folks I got live dates
coming up this Thursday April 6th I'll
be in Stamford Connecticut at New York
comedy club April 20th Cleveland Ohio at
dunlap's Corner Bar two shows that night
uh you sold out the first one we added a
second and I think the second one is
almost sold out too April 21st and 22nd
Columbus Ohio at the attic Comedy Club
we're doing four shows there Baltimore
Maryland on April 28th and 29th at the
Port Comedy Club four shows uh and then
May 3rd New York New York crane theater
the I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
residency that might be the last time we
do this in New York uh so I don't know
yet but anyway come out to that show
come out to all the shows
jodarosainfo.com for all show
information and tickets and of course if
you're in New York come to Joey roses
open seven days a week 11 30 a.m every
day food
drinks fun it's a great time
joeyrosesnyc.com
[Music]
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds
hey Tasties and buddies welcome to tea
so it's new now we have two you have
tasty Santa oh yes Tasties and buddies
Tasties Tasties is a late onset yeah
it's like dementia it's late on set the
late offset nickname and we had the same
talk last time you don't remember
Tasties last time yeah but I'm just
saying like it's only the second time
we're talking about Tasties oh oh third
third not to criticize if you're a fan
I'll take a poll if you're a taste buds
fan we should probably hold would you
rather I think people are going to be
prone to Buddies because it's it's been
the the staple
but I also think it's tasty is pretty
fun tasty she can't deny that tasty
tasty sounds a little more sexual
yeah it does like it sounds like you
have a fetish of some kind it does we're
tasty like like um this is in sexual but
it reminds me of Bronies the guys that
are into My Little Pony which I don't
think is sexual I think they're Tasties
reminds me of rhonies
there's a oddness to the work I'm going
to keep saying Tasties but there's an
oddness to that term
there's an oddness to it right yeah but
think about this let's give you just a
person and your nickname was tasty
that's pretty that's pretty good man
like oh [__] Tasty's here it sounds like
a pimp
yeah it does it's so there's a sexual
quality to it I would be cold tasty I
wouldn't balk at that if someone called
me tasty I think I would like it I I I
wouldn't scoff at it I'm just I just you
just can't deny you guys if someone if
someone if some somebody did you just
spill
Cherry Cola all over the floor I thought
this was
V can you do me a favor
I didn't realize this was regular Cherry
Coke I thought it was Coke Zero Cherry
Coke Zero Cherry what kind of Niche
refrigerator do you think we have here
maybe you got [__] peach iced tea
zero out there that's my jam yeah I Jam
is Coke Zero Cherry not that I thought
you were stalking accordingly here but I
just thought it was all diet soda they
do a Coke Cherry zero oh yeah it's me
and Jay's favorite soda ever okay is it
better than diet Dr Pepper
it's it's not even a contest it makes me
upset to even say that I don't know
because diet Dr Pepper tastes a lot like
regular Dr Pepper if you get yeah
somehow from some chain of events you
got the nickname tasty from people would
you enjoy it
I want
no I mean it is what it is I mean
someone calls you tasty they don't have
to know why the reason is but no it's
just
Tasty's funny right what about you pimp
yeah I wouldn't mind I don't care what
you call me tasty yeah pause before the
answers yeah
um uh by the way I've fed both your
images into a new AI that makes art from
people's faces which image which image
you choose as the uh your head shot that
gets slapped on every theater I chose
your headshots that you both prefer no
no I don't prefer anything people just
take those and I hate the ones they take
oh well I fed one you hate that which
one the one where you're like cross arms
from I don't know maybe 28 glasses no
glasses oh no do I have no beard
I can't recall you'll see the AI art is
way different than the image did you get
the image I have the image you saw it
with a [__] image that I'm going to get
[__] results well you don't know that it
might it might fix it well let's have a
little while let's have a look all right
let's see what's the process you have to
pay for this yeah I have a membership
I'm gonna use it in my work I'm gonna
use AI stuff so this is just kind of the
beginning it's is it instant it's
instant you know on The Daily Show when
they're like imagine Putin riding a
thing I could have it make that image in
two seconds oh so people don't need so
people that go to it it's not great
what's happening people that go to an
interview with resume that says
photoshop on it can go scratch their ass
now if you're a graphic designer or a
guy who makes Flyers God bless you I'll
see you around no but you're
contributing to the problem though
they're coming after me too why don't I
just hop on
right you can't ask everybody to just
hold it down like all right guys
everyone don't use AI the camera guys
are like I'm film only see you yeah
so let's see but that also means that we
get to stop paying hundreds of dollars
of Flyers yeah we should do AI flyers
for the live event
yeah but oh man I I really don't want to
start with a [__] [__] photo well we you
can show me a good photo we can make
another one so when you when you put it
in and you say whatever you say what
like make a drawing of this or whatever
you say uh 80s art in the style of a
random artist you write that description
is that your own words or is that a
preset thing no it's just me knowing how
to feed the machine oh wow okay okay so
okay and is it do you hit it and then it
comes back instantly uh maybe a minute
maybe really it depends if it's rush
hour I get charged more and it might be
too rush hour is Rush Hour use oh yes
Jackie Chan yeah I got you and you know
what else is weird you can see in real
time what everyone else is requesting be
done and it's just like companies how
much is a membership to this couple
hundred bucks look how they make it look
like Twitter oh yeah look they're sell I
fed this one that's fine which did you
feed him me oh geez uh there's she
you you why you're seeing everyone else
who has a membership this is an open
public forum
oh so you're you're putting that request
in in public well no on a timeline no
one's paying attention to the timeline
the timeline's overwhelmed this is for
like uh people experimenting with the
software for the first time this is this
room this is frightening that it's that
it's a community thing yeah yeah oh that
looks
Improvement it's like four versions of
you what an increase movement wait does
it say to make an improvement no and
then I say refine image three but put it
more Salvatore Dali in it and then
something else happens is that what you
said no but I could that's what I like
to do all right so let's let's look at
this so first of all you got let's do
one two three four so one top left two
top right three bottom left four bottom
right which one do you think looks most
like you to start
all right
I think I got it I think I got it
yeah I think I got it I got it they all
don't look like you and they all do look
like you which is freaking me out I know
they don't look like you but they do
look like you does that make sense to
anybody yeah it makes perfect sense
I guess that's what it called a
resemblance I'm a little out of it today
a minute ago I had forgotten that we had
started the podcast really yeah and I
thought we were just talking
um I'm gonna pick with the one I think
looks most like me I don't say anything
everybody got an answer
everybody one that looks like him the
most the most out of those four okay
okay and you know this the number
sequencing or just tell me which one I
think okay ready what do you think Joe
top right because the eyes are the most
uh similar top right was mine mine too
and the hair is closest on the top I
said number three bottom left I'll take
a number three I think that's number two
if I'm being honest the top left looks
like a young Bill Murray yes
and the bottom right looks like a it
looks like a like a like way off like
Chris Pine or something yeah that's way
off bottom left is a little too John
Hamm
uh bottom left looks the most 80s to me
though actually 80s yeah he that's what
you put in right 80s 80s style yeah
bottom left looks like the most I gotta
get my hair cracking like this top right
you got a little the bottom left has a
little bit of a like a I don't know I
don't you look like um
like a like a like somebody that was on
the original Apple team over at Tandy or
something like that yes I agree with
that yeah that bottom left yeah but the
bottom left guy the most richest one is
the Tandy left bottom left yes bottom
right is you
if you modeled in uh if you modeled like
uh uh uh uh
uh what was that old what was that
really popular old clothing brand for
guys no no no no
that what
did I guess you said you were out of it
today because I think you're right where
you need to be
[__] how did you guess that bro
because whoever we all love Bugaboo
Bugle Boy
and then just what they just went the
way of the dodo it just it ran its
course you know people they need
multi-colored shirts yeah but why didn't
they just adapt to the times you could
still be wearing Bugle Boy somebody
should resurrect it as a matter of fact
probably I think it was such a specific
style and you get you talk about old
school yeah it was such a specific style
I don't think they could have
I think you couldn't pivot at that point
that's not Bugle Boy
[Laughter]
honestly I would love to I would love to
wear that just the top you don't have to
leave it on the bottom I would love to
wear the whole thing actually the top
and no bottoms I would love to wear the
whole thing if you walked into this room
naked with just that top pixelated
survive it pixelated
if I [__] wore it I'd kill myself
if I swear to God if V wasn't here I
would do that I would have no problem
with it
hey
in the room where you bottomless
she's talking about biting
pixelation out put it in front of his
garage
huh yeah yes yes yeah
wow
none of those look like me I disagree
I'll tell you who this is I'll give you
the whole rundown right now
so the top right looks like like wait no
no we got to do the vote again oh yeah
we did this isn't it's insane everybody
make their picks I think this is I think
AI has failed me I think AI has failed
me
this is an easy one you think it's an
easy one absolutely
really abso [__] lutely
man I don't see it is one that for a
million dollars I wouldn't say that it
looks like me
uh no I agree that's why I'm saying the
one that it looks like you is very easy
number four looks like Dahmer
it looks like Dahmer it looks like um it
looks like uh it looks like Thomas
middle ditch it looks like Thomas
middleich it looks like uh it looks like
Sam from Whitest Kids
yeah it looks a lot like shampoo it
looks like will facts and a little bit
my other guy that does art on my show it
looks like Tom middle ditch it looks
like Dahmer I don't know that there's
I'm just gonna say my pick there's no
resemblance no that one's bad or as far
as a resemblance I mean it's bad top
left is you all the way
top left 100 looks like you the top left
100 looks like that looks like to me
that looks like uh
I don't know it looks like it looks like
an Elvis impersonator it looks obviously
but it looks like that's not my hair
really yeah one the right the top right
looks like Neil Brennan [__] Andrew
Schultz
absolutely top rights got top rates got
a little veteran it too a little Vita in
it the bottom left that one looks like
it's not finished or something I think
we should take a photo of you guys
together right now and feed it in and
see what it does we could do that yeah
in real time like this yeah just boom
boom take a photo of them here sit
together so I could feed it a photo
should I take my hat off yeah but I have
a slicked hair going on I don't need
that well it's going to change your hair
nobody needs that wait what let me
let's see what happens
I think I was failed by the AI there I
think you I don't know why you had
glasses there's no glasses in the
reference photo that's what's confusing
they just
maybe that's 80s
okay
um we also have well that's I mean Hello
everyone's doing it take a selfie take a
selfie V you're getting put in pimps
you're getting put in well that's the
game while that feeds I got some update
I gotta I got an interesting turn of
events
there's nothing better that I like as
far as events goes in a turn of them yes
me too yeah uh guess who got dmed
by the gummy bear company themselves
Haribo yes no you didn't they dm'd me no
he said can we send you some let me get
hold on what were you gonna send and
then he didn't get diarrhea Ben Frank
laughs no fancy
diary sounds like diarrhea and I just
added the in front
I I full disclosure
full disclosure did I ever tell you this
the story about Boz Scaggs
hold on no go ahead I'm just I wanna no
I'm just I'm listening I'm just I'm just
saying hold on because I'm pulling this
DM up but you can
uh a long time ago as code to I gotta
I'm gonna ship myself I used to say I
got a van I got a little bit of Anne
Frank going because diary sounds like
diarrhea and just we just wanted like
twice removed we didn't want people to
know that you had to shoot yourself so
people like I have a little bit of a
diary going but you don't want to say
diary because it sounds like diarrhea so
we would just go I gotta Anne Frank no
disrespected Frank God bless that that
woman you know right I love it I mean
God bless her and all that all that good
stuff you know she's terrific but I got
yeah she's a great writer so there's no
disparagement here I'm just saying that
diary sounds like diarrhea but if you
say diarrhea it still sounds like
diarrhea so you say Anne Frank and then
you know that I meant diary diarrhea
right yeah
I'm sure people would love it
all right Haribo
dude did you see my picture I passed
Terrible's main [__] I passed there this
week on the road yeah I was driving
between like
Green Bay and they also responded and
said they were heartbroken by your
stance
no I I just texted that to you
I know ass okay
when they saw the episode I think they
did yeah but they got to understand
something they gotta understand what we
do here
no no I know I don't think they're
literally heartbroken I think they were
just saying now you're calling horrible
Liars yeah well a little bit it's all
game I mean come on there's big money
we're dealing with here uh Hey Joe
you're officially invited to celebrate
the debut of GN GB Haribo USA's very own
News Channel premiering on National
gummy bear day the happiest stories
celebrating gummy bears your faves we
heard wink Emoji all right here on
Instagram we'd love to send a little
something special your way to celebrate
the big day mind sending us a good
mailing address which I haven't done yet
should I not put my home address in here
well now that you set it on on the thing
I don't think they'll know it's your
home address
oh you can put it to here but someone
has to be hitters
um wait I have a question
I love this where's the part where they
were heartbroken about me they they just
responded I think on like Twitter or
something or to the clip I think it was
on Instagram
well Waylon my nerds
nerd gang he is about this
uh I'm gonna put the bar in here it's
done already
what style did you put in pimp I said uh
buddy comedy movie poster but it didn't
really take right I'm gonna put photo
realistic portrait look what it did to
you guys
I can't really see it because it's a
little small this one none of those look
like oh wait I'm looking at Sal thinking
that's supposed to be me
these are none of these look like either
of us
so what else happened with the DM
what do you mean that was it I'm just
responding now with my address I passed
a bar address I want to do office work
you know on offline
you know what it is it's engaging for
the listeners to hear silence while you
type well I I thought you guys were
going to talk about the I understand
that we don't understand
sorry I just was afraid I was I know I
know I know I'm bad I'm not good at all
right you're not good at what I I'm not
good at like putting something I'm not
good at multitasking I'm trying to say
Jesus Christ
I passed the Haribo
Game Headquarters uh this weekend on the
road I was either on my drive from Green
Bay it was to Milwaukee or Milwaukee to
Chicago but uh yet it says Haribo and
like it's 80 foot letters across the yes
across and the day and the day should
have just went in there and be like
surprise just through nerds the day
after we recorded the the Capri Sun
battle
I sent you that picture I was in a
[__] coffee shop
in uh Louisiana in Baton Rouge and they
had the 100 juice Capri Suns I've never
seen those before
isn't that weird gotta open your eyes
they're all over yeah I guess so right
uh buddy texted me saying that he just
bought a pack and they've changed the
recipes and he's was unhappy with it
wait they changed the recipes of 100
juice the original flavors what's the
original flavors it was like a citrus
like an orange what is that
what is that what the [__]
what is that something weird take on you
guys what
I don't even get it did you tell it to
do that no I'm just trying to figure out
what problem the bottom left looks like
David crossfuck Carl Malden
top left looks like literally like a
circus clown [__] Clint Eastwood
I don't even understand what these
interpretations are oh my God top right
looks like Joey Diaz all right go back
to that
does it not
no maybe not top right no this isn't it
wait this isn't it it's changing in real
time sorry no it's not this can't get
more freaky top left looks like Nick
Cage now it has me oh no I'm on the
right who are you glasses I'm the old
guy you look like you look like Giannis
on the bottom left that's you that's
supposed to be you dude this thing no no
no no no no no that's you every guy with
glasses is you
they just switched where was we both
have glasses no but in the bottom left
I'm the glasses oh my God the bottom
left looks like uh who's the guy from
the bird cage and here you guys want to
get more involved Ethan Lane Lathan Lane
mixed with Giannis Papa's bottom left
you can click which one to say this is
the right style continue there on this
style
wow so which one should we choose one
two three or four but
where is where is the I don't understand
what it's doing where's the where's the
third one it's making me look old in
every one of them this is also going to
make like this is making people not need
to acquire skill sets which I don't like
yeah we're this is bad guys why why do
anything when you could get instant
results just doing this and the thing is
with this
uh like with anything else like Twitter
like nicotine like whatever thing that's
the newest fad that's potentially
dangerous people are just
look at this or the fact that they made
this a social media Network in order to
get people as tied up in this as as much
as they can and constantly just
to hit fast forward on this this is so
bad this is Terminator [__] I will tell
you this is Terminator [__] I will tell
you this if you put that in front of me
and said who are these two people I
would never guess we're seeing you maybe
put it in the filter that you did for
the other one the 80s did you know this
I think I might have talked about this
on here before did you know there is now
because you know deep fake technology is
like so uh like so it's off the chain
yeah there's a porn app now
where you can put any woman's face on
the woman that's getting [__] in the
in the uh video you know it's so
different to the young sorry young kids
but there it's so to the people having
sex you can change their faith like
that's so crazy and dangerous and sick
too that you could make a video of any
person you want to be having sex with
you could just make it happen guys I'll
be right back
it's so objectifying and weird I'll be
back in 10 minutes you know
it's very weird uh it's not this is this
is not good stuff so does that mean but
it won't that's the reason that people
could also like
do a same-sex variety porn and then put
our faces on yes please
I've been trolled where people have put
my face on like
like a in a gay porn thing where there's
a huge dick
most of the young fans well I'm sorry I
forget that we have young fans I don't
know if we do uh no we do but if we do
you're really you're laying into it but
we've had like but you know what I mean
like but my point is is like I actually
even though we're the people it was
people trolling me maybe it should be
18-0 but this should be 18 and over it
may no we have younger fans they've come
to the bar with their parents and said
that we're fans of taste but sorry guys
sorry guys please to get a sandwich not
to drink obviously
kids come down
172 or something but no they they
um it made me laugh even though I was
getting trolled because of the skill it
took to do it and how creative it was I
thought it was really funny yeah and
this is like you're right this is taking
away from it what's Wild here is first
of all what shirts are we wearing
they just made them up
and what's crazy is it's picking up the
titles of ourselves behind ourselves
this you're the one with the glasses in
in two of these dudes I told it 80s
style and have it these two men enjoying
ice cream
[Laughter]
that's very funny the bottom right sort
of sort of the bottom right which one
are you
you're the one on the left oh but no
because look the tattoos on the dude I'm
telling you the bottom left at the
bottom at the in the bottom right one
the left guy at least they captured your
essence in that picture a little bit yes
yes now there is some news with this
they're going to replace models for
product shots with uh AI art like this
what are we what are we doing what are
we doing and the company said they're
gonna do that so that the models are
more diverse
how about just hiring diverse people
that is such a lie that is incredible
what people will do to try to to lie
about saving a dollar let me ask you
this is this copy written from for the
AI I can use this commercially in any
way I want you're kidding me nope I got
the license this morning I could do
whatever I want that was inclusive of
the membership
I mean everyone's gonna lose their job
everybody is going to lose their job and
everybody is rushing head first into
this I get a little mad at one of my
friends what is the graphic designer
gonna do because he keeps sending me
he keeps sending me like AI images while
also being like very aware of how
dangerous this potentially is and I'm
like dude stop feeding it then like if
you think this is like stop but then I
also say to them like there's no hope
like it's the damage is nothing we could
do so you could just have a good time
with it I guess but but it's over I mean
people they've already they're already
doing stuff where
there's a tick tock Channel I mean it's
just a tick tock Channel where it's a
constant Tick Tock of AI Seinfeld it's
not it's it's okay I like it it's funny
enough but my point is is like it's
getting to that point where it's like it
will quickly get to a point where AI
scripts are being generated within I
would say within uh less than two years
I would yeah that that is Newton scripts
are very nuanced
buddy you think look at the crap they
put on television you think they're
gonna bat an eye have you seen a modern
day multicam sitcom I mean it's like
it's like a student play yeah it's
terrible you think they care dude if
they if they can cut a writer's room
they can get rid of a writer's room
because they have a while you know why
they'll be an uprising the first the
first
show to do this
uprisings they're called strikes and
they tell them there's one about to
happen right now yeah yeah no no but but
honestly like I don't want to watch an
AI generator well I do one just to be
like let's see what this does but not
really and I would and I would be happy
let me tell you how any AI related movie
or television show that was let me tell
you how fast that turned nobody wanted
Blockbuster nobody wanted Blockbuster
why because Blockbuster was the
sterilized homogenized soulless
corporate version of a thing we all
loved Blockbuster went into every town
now it's celebrated people remember how
great Blockbuster was it's like what now
they were hard now it's Nostalgia and
now it's it's
I mean it'll turn so fast dude half the
[__] I watch already seems like AI is
writing it it's so it's so bad and then
also people be like you're aiophobic
and or here's what they'll do that's a
term that's gunning we're all aiophobic
here's what they'll do here's what
they'll do too you don't you want it you
want something fresh fun writing you're
watching practically this is Thursday
night to 10 o'clock at on TBS and TruTV
Thursday night to 10 I promise you we
will write it we write it here's how
they'll fix here so here's the thing
they'll do though they'll generate
scripts with AI and instead of having a
writer's room they will hire one writer
who's good so then they'll say doctorate
your job 40 hours a week is to sit with
this script that's already written and
fix it and that's it you just saved
yourself
hundreds of thousands of dollars
South Park already did it they used Chad
gbt to co-write an episode no they
didn't yeah it's already out I haven't
watched it yet but it's already out they
did it already yeah
right yeah yeah but it's a good idea and
it's out already well they can turn over
episodes quickly oh wow that's I see I'd
watch that but you don't know what but
then you don't know what is what like if
you know what what did AI contribute
that's what I really want to know what
jokes what part of the storyline did the
AI contribute and what part did they
change freaky I had AI renovate my
website for me it just the rights code
guys that's not true
how could it get into the code how does
it access your search I just copy and
paste once it makes the code in the chat
and did you did you get an improvement
yeah I'm gonna redo my website it's
gonna be nice but but you've seen it
well look bottom two are actually kind
of kind of close I I've yet yeah because
I've yet to see one that looks like us
like I gotta be honest with you so on
the right track nah those don't look
okay bottom right what does that say
taste Tas Ross what do a t-shirt say
it's it's gibberish
it's taking elements from the photo and
and creating
similar elements like in the clothing
maybe bottom left it's actually
recognizing oh there's a title behind
you let me apply the title to your
T-shirt because it could be on point
with you know what I'm saying this title
could be relevant to what's happening
right now which one of us in the
original picture which one of us was on
it in the bat in the back which one of
us was in the on the sign in the
original picture
oh so it's just okay okay
this is weird man but I don't think
anything worked bottom left Maybe
throw you guys in
I mean all right all right we gotta get
to the battle we can't this isn't an AI
show
can you ask Jesus not yet yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah tune in next week yeah uh
the AI even though we don't wanna
look this kind of frivolous nonsense
might fly on hey babe
we got an agenda on this channel I was
just saying can you ask him today's
battle if they thought the chocolate was
a strawberry milk was better
I
I think here's the next time I think it
is yes can I say one last thing about
this though just just a thought
this is to me what's truly dangerous
about it it will it will not only reduce
employment for creators or all types of
people right we have to rise up it will
all show it will Tick Tock is the number
one search engine
it's the number one search engine like
people will just start to go this is the
entertainment I want why because I could
make this if I wanted that that always
happens
so that's the bigger problem you're
talking from the standpoint of a guy who
wants a certain level of quality you all
the dumb asses out there that'll just be
like I don't care I'll just look at my
AI Jetta writer all day that's what
people will do and that's what the bulk
of people will do
you know Wild
I'm I gotta buy a house and just give up
pressed
optimistic about all this we will always
want human interest that's stupid I'm
kidding I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding why do you think we're okay wait
where do you think we're gonna be in
five years I think that we're gonna be
using this a lot more but I think that's
still people are gonna be waiting for
like human interaction like they
everybody always craves it there's like
there's a total wave of these things
right now human interaction sure but but
human work forget it yeah Bill Gates
came out and said it's the biggest
threat to humanity ever
it's wild I mean V look
look with stuff like this subtitle I
can't wait for this [__] thing to
sometime
I mean I mean Instagram already has like
a good subtitle like feature it's decent
enough that if you don't if you don't
care you're like whatever you know what
I mean like they're gonna create these
like AI like oh AI like here's a program
where AI will run your social media
that's so bad it's so bad you should be
you should be more upset about this
I'm not I'm pretty optimistic all right
yeah but you got to come down on these
companies that are
gonna gonna start replacing humans with
with I mean I know it already happens
but I just mean like to this extent I
mean come on you gotta
you have to veto these types of people
there is you can't you gotta take can
take the power away from them there is
there was a thing that was happening uh
this is the AI weighing in on chocolate
but U.S what's more popular all right
obviously chocolate is more popular I
want to know if it has an opinion on
which tastes better it won't hit you
with an opinion okay okay
that's that's bad too and then I saw
online somebody yeah this is like a side
thing but somebody asked to tell a joke
about Jesus and it did and then it won't
tell a joke about any other savior
I don't know well so further cultivate
and promote opinionist language
opinionless interaction
this is all right let's get off of this
I'm depressed all right ready yes oh
we're doing strawberry milk versus
chocolate milk okay ready yes it's do we
need to do it no let's just get in okay
time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buds all right let's get
come on let's get energy here let's do
it baby I'm energetic better help better
help better help I love better help I
use better help podcast is sponsored by
Better Health that is true it is true I
I am currently uh with better help and
doing therapy with better help I love
this product or this service rather so
much
um look I recently hit what I would call
Crossroads maybe an impasse in my life
and I to be fair you're hitting
Crossroads left and right but go ahead
well no but it's not meant to be a slide
I'm just telling you that this is even
more valuable to you and honestly a few
lefts and a few less rights that's
correct that would better help therapy
is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding you
know that just as well as I do because
sometimes we don't want to know what we
want or why we react the way we do until
we talk through things exactly and I had
to learn uh what what I had to learn
recently about myself was how to stop
torturing myself over the things I
needed to do stop torturing myself over
the things I wanted to change and start
accepting the realities of what things
are and it better help us
that's the value wow listen to this I
love you this is the nature of the show
uh uh Sal vulcano is in my life
therapists take one please
anyway it can help you through a
licensed therapist who can take you on a
journey of self-discovery wherever you
are you think it's starting therapy give
it to Troy it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule fill out a brief
questionnaire you get master the
licensed therapist you could switch
therapists at any time for no additional
I have started therapy so many times
this was by far the easiest most
convenient and affordable way I have
ever experienced therapy I'm not just
saying that I love better help anyway
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com tastebuds today
you're going to get 10 off that first
month that's better help help.com
tastebuck yeah all right everybody knows
chocolate milk is the most popular
flavored milk yeah the balls on you to
come at it which is milk right now I
will tell you that's [__] crazy I
will tell you this my taste buds don't
lie to me right I think chocolate milk
is delicious it is I don't have Ramadan
I had either of these but I think
chocolate milk is delicious but I
remember
when I was younger the first time I
tasted strawberry milk
um
by the way shout out for me it was
strawberry quick
I didn't like the squeeze the squeeze
straw Strawberry but the thing that
looks like the the mutant slime comes
out of it I mean the color of that [__]
is fresh I mean it's probably all it's
all horrific right but yeah but the old
school Nestle Quick cardboard container
with a tin like manhole top with the the
the the strawberry colored powder in it
we used to take it out and you know and
I used to get the build up of it at the
bottom of the powder and then used to
like hit it again it got really sweet
when when I tasted strawberry I was like
by the way what a funny stand-up jokes
ever this guy beefy funny he was a comic
in Philly his name was beefy funny that
was his name uh
uh he was a comic in Philly he had a
joke where he goes he goes y'all think
the
y'all think the Nestle quit are you
Jewish yes he was Jewish he goes y'all
think the Nestle Quick rabbit hate on
the tricks bunny
I don't know the tricks better handle
the message quick crap and he goes
[__] I had the cereal box
industry locked down
from 78 to 89.
such a funny because it was like it was
right in like the Biggie Tupac beef it
was like it was like so right in the
time for all that it was so shout out to
beefy funny yeah anyway shout out to
beefy funny all right sorry go ahead uh
so for me uh it was it was that so the
first time I had strawberry milk I lit
up man I was like chocolate milk is is
good but like this is strawberry milk to
me was Next Level I I liked it it tastes
better and I'm a chocolate fan I love
chocolate everyone's addicted to
chocolate I'm no different but there's
something about strawberry milk okay so
number one it's not as common and I got
a Perfect Analogy when we were in school
we were in school used to get these
little containers these little pints of
milk of whole milk and every once in a
while they they'd chip a chocolate milk
uh pint in and so you have access to the
chocolate milk they never ever ever
produced or had a strawberry milk one
yeah strawberry milk one is well here's
why it's not as easy to come back the
sack on you right now coming at
chocolate milk first of all ten times
out of ten if you have a glass
of strawberry I'm taking strawberry the
most popular way to drink milk period is
chocolate milk I mean it does it does
regular milk no no oh that might have
been a fun one milk versus chocolate oh
my God if you see if I ever see somebody
drinking a glass of regular milk right
now I'm they're psychotic to me it's
psychotic I drink regular milk all the
time that's well yeah well almost closed
still regular milk case closed
before I departed that's that's the
first thing okay all right chocolate
milk is the way to drink milk period
number two because all the uses for milk
not outside of just drinking milk I'm
talking about just drinking it out of a
glass chocolate milk is the is the
leading way to drink milk
secondly everything you're saying is
true here's why chocolate milk wifey
strawberry milk side piece strawberry
milk will make you feel like a man for a
few minutes and then you go I don't know
what I was thinking I gotta get back
home like I shouldn't have done this
right now that's true to me it's a
Temptation it makes you stray for a
minute you make a mistake
it's delicious while it's happened
I gotta go back to my to my ride or die
right now chocolate milk right it tastes
like a version of chocolate
it doesn't taste like straight up I
don't know man you are so full of I love
chocolate what do you mean a version of
chocolate taste exactly like chocolate
doesn't it taste like a chalky chocolate
straw and you think oh my god listen you
got balls like cassava melons today wow
wow is that a is that a Coming to
America reference no it's a reference to
safeman
safe men you ever see the movie Safe you
just quoted safely one of my favorite
movies ever did you ever see it yeah I I
know someone who's in it who who do you
know in it wait this is yeah your friend
was like a DJ yeah yeah yeah that's the
guy from young black teenagers no he or
he's shrimp no no that you're thinking I
think that DJ scribble yeah I don't
think he's oh wait that's not dj screw
your buddy plays the DJ everybody is a
DJ but he's been in a lot of little he's
just great DJ Cruz or something yeah
he's written movies he's he's been in
movies and and things like TV and the
big fat Bernie Gail the the bad guy at
it yeah
he goes he goes these guys uh I forget
what he said do you remember that coming
to America reference you guys rip off
with you know they they they take us
any guy that'll do that they got balls
besides cassava melons
Coming to America when they have bat in
the beginning when they're battling with
like that like the sticks and he's like
your wife everything was like your wife
need only have a firm backside and big
breasts like a Saba Miller
um
shout out to Safe pen
writer director or safe man went on to
make Meet the Parents
oh Horowitz John Horowitz uh Jay roach I
believe it is isn't it no Jay roach
didn't do me wait no J roach is Austin
Powers writer director is
John Hamburg hamburger I'm thinking I
messed it up with mature with maybe John
Hamburg I met him once he had a broken
arm by the way you want to talk about a
movie it launched the career it is the
it is a showcase for an unknown at the
time Rockwell yeah Zan Ruffalo and
Giamatti for
Heavy Hitters in this thing uh unknown
at the time playing the best versions of
what you want them to play like the BET
like Giamatti playing the insecure like
kind of like uh
Dinklage unknown Dinklage I forgot
unknown Dinklage is a good name for an
improv group that is good Rockwell
playing They're all playing like the
insecure comedic like the things they do
so oh my God Michael Lerner his best
performance yeah that wasn't everything
a big big big movie yeah it was a little
underground right it was a little bit
Independence I would call a sleeper hit
let's call it a sleeper hit
uh all right listen here's the thing do
you got balls the size of cassava melons
today all right because you're saying oh
oh you're gonna say that chocolate milk
doesn't taste like strawberry milk
tastes nothing I mean nothing they both
say strawberry they both taste
artificial but I don't know it's even
and I love the way it looks like a
bright pink uh liquid versus like a like
a dark like chocolate like [__] liquid
Dennis Dennis either it's fun it's fun
it was either see a nice tall glass a
highball glass full of strawberry milk
just the visual incites more of an
appeal uh just like I I like you know
when you when you're when you like want
to taste something it's more officially
attractive than the glass of water milk
it's either Lewis Black or Denis Leary
had a joke about NyQuil where they said
they have it comes in two flavors red
and green and they taste like red and
green that's what strawberry milk tea
strawberry milk tastes like pink it
tastes like what does chocolate tastes
like chocolate
yourself down
the road
[Laughter]
all right you were doing the remix
the remix is in my top 30 favorite rap
songs of all time ah wow yeah yeah 30
yes yes
I have a Perpetual uh playlist where I
keep adding favorite songs and it's up
to like 34. okay and scenario remixes in
there undoubtedly man now fun fact is uh
chocolate milk was discovered in 1700s
strawberry milk was 1940s
right on right on wait say it again pimp
I'm zoned out 1700 chocolate milk
chocolate cacao probably to like to just
unregularly considered adding chocolate
milk to the astronauts diet because of
its nutritional value and price why is
that nutritional value I don't know I
like it the milk has a nutritional value
bodybuilders drink it after working out
because it's good for Muscle Recovery
chocolate milk chocolate is chocolate
has
the qualities like Health Quality to it
like there is a lot not like Coke not
chocolate milk powder they say you
should eat they say you should eat a
piece of chocolate every night after
dinner uh because it's great for
digestion check that box but yeah yeah
but but the peace meaning this not you
know yeah my friend yeah if you don't
like strawberry milk at all
no I like it all right but look
strawberry milk my friend uh Jim always
said
he always said it tastes like melted
lollipop and it does it does kind of
taste like a melted lollipop strawberry
milk yes I don't know it tastes a little
bit like a melted lollipop something
weird I'm excited and I can't have it
anymore right because you can't I don't
want to die early I I I'm a middle-aged
man I can't be drinking I can't be
dumping powder do they still sell it in
that way
it's unfortunate it's unfortunate that
they made that old school box it was
cardboard and Tin they made it into
plastic which is unfortunate but that
old school box is awesome the box was
awesome that's great Yusuf Yusuf alve
says liking strawberry milk should be
added to the red flags that deny people
from boarding planes
containing farms and getting more
you have shelter because they like
strawberries
I went to a mall Santa after having
Nesquik strawberry milk and I puked it
all over them they had to close the
whole Workshop down so I'm going
chocolate strawberry milk tastes like
someone clapped the erasers from school
outside the window and happened that's
not true for nelesky you ever had the
chocolate milk from the store that's so
thick it had it had to have been made
with butter yeah strawberry milk can
take a walk strawberry milk what are you
six oh you're getting close this might
be the worst it does taste strawberry
milk tastes like Pepto-Bismol a little
bit it has that yeah
[Music]
tastes like whatever it wants to taste
like but you if you close your eyes and
I poured Pepto-Bismol to someone's mouth
they wouldn't go it's not even
strawberry I would say they're pink it's
not strawberry strawberry Cherry one huh
did you have the Cherry one growing up
it's Pepto-Bismol yeah it's disgusting
they have cherry flavor I know but it's
disgusting I never heard it was a
tolerable medicine because it tastes
like strawberry milk I'm not saying I'm
not saying you couldn't tell the
difference in a blind taste that's not
what I said you said similarity it does
not pepto-bismol's taste is not
strawberry they don't tout it to be
strawberry it's not meant to be
strawberry it's pink strawberry milk is
for kids that eat glue
chocolate milk is overplayed let me let
me have a one and let me have one pink
milk okay I got somebody
strawberry milk also creates strong
bones but at what cost
chocolate milk is more accessible
therefore will probably win agreed but
strawberry milk is far superior and
definitely slept on and I agree it slept
on uh oh that's not a good sign cell
strawberry milk based on the vote so far
I assume DeRosa is arguing for
strawberry you're getting clobbered
right now
strawberry milk tastes like regret and a
trucker spit on the side walk of a hot
day no thanks why do you write why would
you write something that makes no sense
that's not what it tastes like oh let's
look at this psycho I used to have my
mom make me teeny tiny warm chocolate
strawberry milk which was chocolate and
strawberry milk microwave for 30. they
would mix the two wait you think that
person is nuts because I was just like
oh that piqued my interest I mean like I
mean like you crazy bastard I like what
you're doing because because chocolate
strawberry and then hot
what is that I had no idea strawberry
milk existed
[Laughter]
follow at Josh orenberg
o-r-e-n-b-e-r-g early winner on this one
that's great that's great have you guys
ever dumped this in cereal either no I I
can't I can't go that that far sugary
but I will say this I will say this and
this is is in defense of both my two of
my favorite cereals outside of we've
we've you know we've all talked to
Captain Crunch crunch berries is the
king but two of my favorite cereals
right after that are Cocoa Pebbles and
Fruity Pebbles and Fruity Pebbles will
make the milk sort of taste like
strawberry milk and Cocoa Pebbles will
make it taste like chocolate milk and
those those two cereals are two cereals
where
I would get excited about the milk
afterwards you know everybody drinks the
cereal milk like whatever with frosted
flakes it's fine you know it tastes
pretty good but like but with those two
I'd be like excited like it was like a
second round when you were little yeah
if you swung open the fridge or opened
the cabinet
yes you wouldn't get more excited
at strawberry milk being there then
chocolate I find that hard to believe I
I I stand by my analogy strawberry
chocolate milk is your ride or die
strawberry is a nice diversion once in a
while but dude it's like you strawberry
strawberry is the underdog that came out
300 years later that never got to hold
it the place of rightfully she had
should have which is number one you know
what's odd I love strawberry ice cream I
love strawberry milk I don't love
strawberries because they vert these
don't taste like strawberries that's
what I'm trying to tell you strawberry
ice cream tastes like strawberries no it
doesn't I love strawberries and I love
strawberry ice cream the only part of
strawberry ice cream that tastes like
strawberries is when you get a little
bit of actual strawberry the rest of it
tastes like pink I Can't Describe what
that means it just tastes like it tastes
like um
it tastes like like uh like like Moon
beams you know what I mean it tastes
like Rainbow Bright would eat it do you
know what I mean like it's it's got a
cartoons it is like a chocolate milk uh
I'm sorry hot chocolate is basically
it's not but basically it's chocolate
milk heated up nobody bats an eye but I
can't imagine hot strawberry milk
hot strawberry milk would be disgusting
also when you microwave milk a film
forms at the top of the milk
that's gross does it yeah you ever
microwave milk it's nice this is
interesting this is what pimp just
pulled up this is why fake flavors don't
taste like real Fruit a few chemicals
are enough to give a hint to the flavor
an artificial strawberry flavor does
somewhat resemble a real strawberry in
some cases one molecule gives you the
flavor's essence here's the thing
I've said it all the time banana I love
bananas I hate banana flavor I hate
watermelon I love watermelon flavor the
best flavor of gum like when Bubblicious
and all those were running the scene
great orange grape I was gonna say
strawberry they'd have like slam and
strawberry it tasted nothing like
strawberry but it was so good man it was
so good do you remember Bonkers was that
oh yeah yeah remember remember it was
like Starburst but it was like something
inside of it like this would squirt out
no no see yeah Bonkers see yeah he was
like juicing no that was it juice I
thought it was just like do Bonkers
still exist
well wait what were they though Bonkers
is one of my favorite words yeah it had
like a it had like no but it was I think
it was just chewy yeah chewy inside
Tangy Tangy is also suspect things that
are Tangy name thing I don't like Tangy
no they name things that are Tangy
sometimes people are like oh the
barbecue sauce has a Tang to it I'm like
how much do you miss this this is when
candy was candy made dude they would
drop it would it was it was like it was
like Nas dropping a new album yeah
is that yeah
a green apple
the way the most popular flavor of gum
is peppermint in the U.S that's my
favorite flavor I go spearmint I go
spearmint I have a who came around
though and just gave them both a shot in
the ass went to Green
I I don't like Wintergreen I don't like
I don't like the variations of the mints
Wintergreen is the most icy I don't like
the I hate icy flavor I hate it yeah and
I'm not a big fan of dentine ice I like
dentine but I keep I keep five packs of
gum at all times at my desk with a
variation of flavors I've got a
peppermint there I've got a bubble gum
flavor I've got an orange flavor
original Bubble Gum I've got a
strawberry flavor there see that's the
thing they're all like sugar-free
whatever that's all you can find
anything oh original bubble gum flavor
might be a good battle original Bubble
Gum when you get it right there's
nothing like it yeah it's great yeah uh
I like we you know be fun like double
bubble versus something
you guys do cinnamon gums or no cinnamon
okay it's I like I like big red maybe on
a date you know what's a real
not alone
[Laughter]
too frisky alone there's a friskiness to
a cinnamon gum you know it weird it
feels weird alone
ah you're nuts okay but I think
spearmint is like if I'm going like you
remember Wrigley's used to be a quarter
five sticks for a quarter there's this
experiments
Wrigley's printed it on the pack yeah
like you couldn't change the prices I
know but it did I think they went up to
35 and now I don't even know that they
exist like that I think they pulled the
price off the package yeah well did you
guys hear the dollar slices a dollar
fifty now in New York they still call us
a dollar slice I don't know they
probably try they don't make it easy
can't say a dollar Forever uh we gotta
we gotta get the vote on this man right
where it's about that time let's hear a
closing argument let me just okay let me
just let me just say too Juicy Fruit
what you take on Juicy Fruit
Juicy Fruit
that's a great battle but Juicy Fruit
I'm just saying what do you think about
Juicy Fruit Standalone love it you love
it are you kidding what is the juice
what is this juicy to this day I can't
pinpoint oh banana and pineapple pimp I
don't know why that was in my brain some
say it resembles Jackfruit which is what
I thought closer to I never even sensed
the banana you ever have Jackfruit
that's good I like that stuff
um all right closing argument for sure
everybody used to make fun of the
commercial for Juicy Fruit because
instead
hold on let me DM Haribo real quick
take a sniff pull it out they used to
say put Juicy Fruit Chase is gonna move
me when you pop it in your mouth and and
you've got to be grammar school they
went wild with that yeah you got to be
careful with gum there's a lot there's a
lot of going on beneath the surface yeah
for a 4 foil wrapped stick that you put
in and it like bends for a little square
nugget come on dude wrapped in plastic
where double bubble unwrapping that
thing putting it in we're gonna have a
gun battles
guys
hold on let's hold this for the next
episode we got it we gotta we gotta wrap
up here
all right give your closing argument for
strawberry milk
uh I think that strawberry milk is it
tastes better it looks better visually
I'm more excited to get it because it's
not as common uh I think that chocolate
milk this not only is chocolate milk
common but chocolate everything is
common you can get chocolate every time
because it's king So strawberry milk for
me because it's King it's the one thing
we said that could go against we when we
we're gonna do a I'm not I won't even
tease it but it's not chocolate milk
it's a superfood not in this so my point
being is that like you can have 80
things that have chocolate in there 80
times like I just think strawberry milk
is more of a treat it should be I and I
receive it as more of a treat and that
makes me attach a little bit more of
excitement to it look when I was a kid I
know one thing chocolate milk is great
when I trace tasted strawberry milk I
was like later for you chocolate let's
see I would have only strawberry milk in
the house let's see I didn't want
chocolate milk anymore let's see how
much that's enough for me to say
all right in my heart of hearts
strawberry milk is is better even right
now I haven't had a glass of
strawberries in so long I would love a
glass of strawberry milk okay
my closing argument is this
a pink drink my closing argument is this
chocolate
milk
give us the vote
honestly I thought it was even worse
so there you go you got your humble pie
I'm eating it I'm eating 75 to chocolate
milk 22 the strawberry milk I still love
you I love you too taste buds they come
into the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two Fool's gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man